[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jill's
with us in Phoenix hi Jill how are
you I'm well thank you so much thanks
for taking my call sure what's
up so I'm calling uh I've listened to
the show off and on for years but I got
really serious about six months ago and
um I so I I'm GNA admit at the outst
start that I know I've messed
up but
um I have about $100,000 of debt with my
ex-husband I'm currently married um my
current husband and I make good money um
because this debt felt so overwhelming I
kind of shoved it to the side we paid
off all of our other debt um and I
started saving for a house I went to
basically I skipped partial step two and
went to step three and we started saving
we paid so all your you and your current
husband paid off all your other prear
your debts from the other marriage
except this debt and what is this debt
how big is
it it's
$100,000 and the IRS oh okay and how did
you end up $100,000 in debt to the
IRS so uh my former husband owned a
company um tax issues got complicated um
life was really overwhelming he didn't
want to deal with it I didn't know how
to deal with it so we just didn't file
seven years of
taxes yikes yeah so when we got divorced
wait minute did you have an income
during that time you personally I did I
did and you didn't file taxes on that
income um so did you file taxes on your
income during the seven years no no okay
so his business was complicated you
didn't file on it and how did the
$100,000 come about who decided what
that was
so when we were getting divorced we
actually hired a CPA which is what we
should have done in the first place and
they went through filed all of our taxes
and let us know you know what we owed as
well as uh initially interest and
penalties and of course why in the world
did you file filing jointly or you're
going through a divorce why didn't you
file separately you would have only been
responsible for the taxes on your
income the judge required it
unfortunately
inter I
know I don't believe
you I think your attorney mailed it in
judges that's not that's not logical the
judge required you file your freaking
taxes I don't I don't argue that but
that he didn't file you he didn't
require you you were as liable that
you're had to pay taxes on his business
that he didn't file
on so because the the judge basically
said well you better benefited from the
income while you were married so you are
both jointly and severally liable and
you have to file together it was very
very
frustrating so the ex I have a question
about your ex-husband is he going to if
you both said all right it's $100,000 I
pay 50 you pay 50 is he gonna is he
going to do it no it's joint andal she's
leled for all of it until it's all
paid through the divorce um he is
obligated to pay 60 % and I'm obligated
to pay 40 and that's kind of part of the
question is should just try to pay the
40,000 he's not no he's not the divorce
decree says that but the IRS says you
owe a
100 correct the IRS will not acknowledge
that exactly they don't have to I pay
the hundred and I can take him back to
court and sue him for that portion yeah
good luck with that or I
know and
honestly I it wasn't until I called a
smart investor Pro because I started
saving for a house and I had my
emergency fund I was savings for a house
and um your smart investor Pro was like
no no girl you got to go back to step
two you have to deal with this yes you
got to deal with it right so how much
money do you have laying
around so I have
$55,000 okay um part of that was money
that I got from uh my son passing away
and part of that is money we saved gosh
okay I I got to tell you there's a
couple courses you can go through here
one course you can go through is you can
pay the 100,000 and hope you get his 40
back out of him and I wouldn't give you
much hope for that and you move on with
your life that's a fairly easy course to
take that's the clean course that's the
easy one okay here's the one I would do
though and it's the hard one okay um I
would hire another CPA or rather a tax
attorney and I would go and uh go back
before the probate courts where the
where the divorce was done and check
challenge that judge's ruling and refile
under the innocent spouse provision cuz
I don't think you're liable for his
taxes and you're innocent of his is the
thing ask your C ask your tax attorney
about the innocent spouse provision this
is where a spouse just signs off on
everything and the other spouse is
running the business and then and they
just sign off on it then they don't get
half the thing they get out they get out
scotf free and you'd be liable for your
income the taxes on your income during
that seven years but not on the
business's income and I'm challenging
that judge's ruling if I'm you it's
going to cost you 10 grand to do this I
was going to say how much would you
spend to do that yeah and but I would do
it this is the Ramsey
Show